[Music]
39 million visa-free travelers from more
than 60 countries are expected to visit
the EU in 2020
a new system should deal with these
travelers is called ETS the European
travel information and authorization
system non EU foreign citizens who want
to come to EU countries will need to
apply for travel authorization before
they arrive it will be an easy process
they have to go through and is just from
an online Trek which they can do it
prior to travel here's how a GIS is
expected to work travellers fill in an
online form and pay a 7 euro fee people
under 18 and over 70 won't have to pay
the application is automatically
processed it looks at personal data
travel documents and answers to
background questions like destinations
and contact information the application
is then checked against security
databases if the person poses a
migration or epidemic risks or a threat
to security access could be refused
Edge's authorization should be valid for
up to 3 years the most important thing
is to provide security and secure our
citizens this pre travel screening
should not cause hassle to travelers but
rather save their time and above all
lead to a safer Europe
[Music]